Chinn Bauhaus here and immediately
people think of places like this and the
movement whose free thinking
revolutionised architecture certainly
that's true in Dessau at the new museum
housed within what's called the black
box which itself is enveloped by glass
something people here hope will wow all
who see it I wanted to be surprised
after they cross this glass facade with
the quality of this opening space and
also to be constructed when they enter
in the black box and then they go to
this intimate world of the Bauhaus of
elephant room one of the defining
aspects of the Bauhaus is that for many
people it has many different definitions
from its inception in the world of
architecture through modern art to
furniture design and all of it
encapsulating the freedom of expression
as this concept enters its second
hundred years here the first hundred
exhibits that were shown in the first
Bauhaus are preserved offering us a
window on an era when the founder of the
school Vatika pious encouraged his
students to abandon old teaching styles
and to embrace the new
Dorthea Braille is one of the curators
here she says part of the museum's task
is to show Bauhaus was a living
breathing entity and not just something
that can be treated as a piece of
history there are the famous names and
there are the famous
iconic objects but there also there's
also very rich production of the
students here who are maybe less known
but who were the center of the Bauhaus
in there so when the movement began
Germany was emerging from the ruins of
the First World War and beginning life
as a democracy now its latest
democratically elected leader has come
to pay homage 100 years after its
founding were still filled today the
fascination of the Bauhaus project bajas
ideas Bauhaus architecture Bauhaus art
and design influenced us today in the
way we build in the way we live in and
shape our world for generations of
architects and artists by
House has been a watchword for cutting
edge design now true to form its hope
this new museum will show that to its
best effect
Dominic Kane al Jazeera daesil